[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT FEIGAL: Google
opens a new cloud
region in the Netherlands.
What does that mean and why
are we so proud of that?
I'm Matt Feigal, and when I'm
not working on the Google Wind
project to guarantee
sunny skies,
my team helps companies
in the Netherlands
learn how to use Google Cloud.
Let's start with the question
of what a region means
in the first place.
With this opening, Google
Cloud Platform products
are now offered and hosted
from the Netherlands.
That makes us the 14th Google
Cloud region in the world.
So here, on the spot where
Google's transatlantic cable
enters Europe, we now have a
state-of-the-art data center
that houses our Google
Cloud Platform products.
The great thing is our
Netherlands data center
is one of the largest and
most efficient data centers
in the world.
Everything you need
to set up your cloud
and make it scalable,
you will find here--
from compute to big data,
storage, and networking.
We are especially
proud of this location
because it's all
about green energy.
Together with Eneco,
we have invested
in a wind farm that supplies
the energy for this data center,
making it completely
CO2 neutral.
For our customers, this means
better performance, lower
latency, and more flexibility.
You can choose to allocate
your applications or storage
environment in one
place or spread them
over multiple locations.
In the Netherlands, we have
so many great local customers
like bol.com, nu.nl,
MessageBird, Weeronline,
Blendle, and Philips
Hue to name a few.
Take Philips
Lighting for example.
It's incredibly important
that the Hue platform
works as quickly as possible.
If you switch your light
on or off via the app,
it's important that your
light responds right away.
Because Philip Lighting runs
the entire back end on our Cloud
Platform, their users
see great performance,
even if the signal
goes all the way back
to your lamp via satellites.
For me, the most
important reason
to open a region
in the Netherlands
is because we are here
for the long term.
Here at Google, we are serious
about the cloud business.
And now, we are
your new neighbor
right here, right next door.
Consider this an invitation.
Feel free to reach
out or even visit us
about how we can help
you to use Google Cloud.
Talk to you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]